leaping out of your skin and in theatres
leaping in time what's it be like
changing that time period for you nice
it's been great it's one of the great
things about this profession is you know
one day you can be caked in mud driving
around in Cornwall and the next you can
be sitting at a dinner table with making
sweet good hair it's it's been great and
and the series year series four starts
in about three four weeks and yeah it's
very exciting to see what's happening
with those characters as well what have
you enjoyed most about playing Tom so
far I think his journey has been his arc
throughout the series has been quite
interesting and he's been a bit of a
victim of circumstance and and for that
I think I've enjoyed kind of watching
Tom grow and turn into this character
that is quite important in that snow
which is very far removed from where he
started you as much of a rebel as Thomas
you think I wish no I'm not I'm not I'm
not as political as him either
fine you've got the imitation game
coming up with a little bit about that
yeah it's a better life of Alan Turing
and said of Bletchley Park and suppose
the goings-on of the Enigma code and his
life and it's an amazing script Benedict
Cumberbatch's playing that so I'm really
excited about that I have a first
costume fitting of the day and yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be amazing
are you excited to be making your first
Hollywood movie yeah well it's very much
a British movie I think and there's kind
of an incredible director and it's just
very exciting are you looking forward to
working with Benedict Cumberbatch yeah
yeah me I'm look that cast is incredible
such as this Benedict it's Keira
Knightley and it's it's a bit the pinch
yourself Castle it's gonna be pretty
amazing
you